ça c'est dans un climat tendu que
dionnet jospin entamera demain un voyage
de quatre jours aux antilles en effet la
martinique et la guadeloupe sont en
proie à des troubles sociaux depuis
plusieurs semaines une situation qui est
aggravée par la crise du secteur
bananier il ya encore plusieurs
centaines de planteurs ont manifesté
leur colère à basse terre la guadeloupe
où une opération île morte a même été
prévue à l'occasion de la visite du
premier ministre reportage sur
l'ambiance qui règne là bas michel
lemaire et et victor arich
une cliente qui loue une chambre à les
côtes elle ne perçoit pas nécessairement
l'étrangeté de la situation c'est le
personnel qui depuis trois ans à la
suite d'un conflit social occupe et gère
l'établissement
la chambre de commerce propriétaire des
lieux leur avait coupé l'électricité ils
ont acheté un groupe électrogène qui
permettait que l'airé chichement les
lieux mais l'établissement n'accueille
pas que des clients il sert aussi de
base logistique à lui j'étais j'ai c'est
ici que les syndicats ont préparé la
mobilisation pour la venue de lionel
jospin et décider de l'opération une
morte vendredi et samedi
nous voulons manifester notre ras-le-bol
lance le syndicat il ajoute rejoints par
d'autres organisations ce cri d'alarmé
la guadeloupe est en train de couler un
thème repris bien au delà des zones
d'influencé des syndicats malaise c'est
clair non on voit que la loi de l'opr
c'est la faillite et
pratique 30 % de chômeurs d emploi le
plus souvent précaire des conflits à
répétition qui paralyse la vie
économique de l'île une insécurité
croissante le constat à de coin qui
était avec au surplus un dialogue social
souvent au point mort
un patronat d'un autre âge un syndicat
indépendantiste non dénués d'arrière
pensées politiques
lionel jospin vous leurrez mettre sur la
table ce dossier des relations sociales
les syndicats sont dubitatifs depuis 50
ans mais ils sont un gouvernement avec
les émissions qu'ils envoient le premier
ministre ils dorment là ministre des
colonies et des puits jospeh s'il a du
même coup elle ce qu attendent avant
tout de ce voyage les antillais ce sont
des mesures concrètes sur l'emploi
l'insertion des jeunes
et s'il était déçu dans ce domaine cette
fois la situation sociale risquerait de
très gravement se détériorer